so um my name is mark horowitz uh i
am not an after dinner speaker like your
previous speaker is
i actually am kind of a nerd and i give
kind of really technical talk so
i apologize ahead of time um
i will say that the one tie-in i'll say
to tom's talk is that i've been studying
technology for a long time
and i've been involved in that for
people who know me i've been involved in
ic business for over 30 years and and my
comment about the ic business is that
we're now in the age of cup holders
and you know i'm barely old enough to
remember when cars were sold by how big
the engine was and how many doors you
had because that really mattered and
then cars had enough of an engine and
enough doors that people didn't care
about that anymore and he started buying
cars because it had a really cool cup
holder or electric windows or electric
door locks right and so you're buying
this very expensive piece of capital
equipment because of relatively small
features okay
roll forward 30 years or so we are now
in the age of electronic cup holders
and we are going to buy devices because
they have this cool widget and i can
talk to some other widget or something
like that and that's really what's going
to end up selling products and i think
the driving you know everything tom says
might be true but the driving thing over
here is we're going to have to convince
you to buy a new thing and we're going
to convince you by giving you features
you didn't have before and that is going
to take a little piece of silicon and
probably a wireless communication device
and we can do that because
us
stupid people in this technology
business decide we're going to spend
millions of dollars hundreds of millions
of dollars to develop something and then
sell it to you for a dollar
and so you can buy this amazing
technology for relatively low
low cost um and as a result we're
already seeing things everything has a
chip in it right my favorite example is
you know the singing cards
we have really disposable technology
it's a fairly complicated chip you open
it once you listen to the song and you
throw it out
right so the next thing is with all the
great technology and wireless is
happening we're now going to have things
that not only are really cheap and can
compute but you know they communicate so
it's the internet okay but for those of
us who
have been around
being saying that you have the internet
and everything is kind of scary right
because
it's actually worse than you probably
imagined it to be
these are articles just from the past
year about how the internet of things
could kill you hacking the fridge
phillips
phillips has this really cool lighting
system called hue right where you can
remotely control your lights well that
means somebody who wants to break into
your house can turn all your lights out
before they break into your house right
you know it's bad enough when people
break into your computer and make it a
zombie and they use it for nefarious
things but you don't notice it's much
worse than when they break into your car
or your sprinkler system and turn your
sprinklers on or turn your house lights
off or whatever
and and there was actually recents that
i didn't put it up here from hp where
they just bought on the market ten
internet of things things seven of the
ten
had basically
major security holes you know i think it
was over fifty percent of them did
unencrypted updates
okay that means if you knew it you could
just download software that you did
anyhow
so as tom said you know you should or a
person said you know you should be a
little worried
i'm a little worried so
there are a group of people at stanford
and actually some faculty from berkeley
and the university of michigan michigan
as well
who
think that
let's not repeat the internet
right you know the internet was a good
thing but we now have all these security
issues wouldn't it be wise to think
about some of these issues a little bit
ahead of time and try to build an
architecture that's a little bit more
secure
so we're starting up we're sending up a
new research program
hopefully with a five-year horizon where
we hope to create essentially an
underlying architecture
of how to think about the internet of
things that can give you security
and in order to do that you have to
think about systems cryptography
applications analytics networks a whole
bunch of
different things all the way to human
computer interactions because it turns
out if you don't worry about the person
you'll build systems that are just
broken in really obvious ways
and that's why it's a relatively large
group of people and what i'm going to do
in this talk is just describe a little
bit about what we're doing in this areas
and one of the things i want to say is
that we think about security i think
about security in terms of two basic
ideas there's data security and this has
to do with a lot about privacy it's like
the data that this system is collecting
about me how hard is it for someone to
steal
and then there's this overall system
security which is how hard is it for
someone to muck into that system and
basically start messing with it so you
can have something where the data is
very secure but it's still relatively
easy for people to get in and muck
around you know and that's one of the
things that we're trying to get is
because you know as tom said it's it's a
it's an escalation war so even if you
build a secure system it's likely
someone will break in you want it to be
that when they break in they still can't
get too many things in value
okay so
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
internet of things i think of a slide
tom already talked enough about it i'm
going to talk a little bit about why iot
security is hard
and then just to give you a flavor about
the things that we're planning to do now
i can't tell you all the wonderful
things we did because we haven't done
anything yet i'm an honest guy so i
won't claim we solved the problem yet
but i i think we'll get
hopefully i'll give you a
enough of a reason to believe that
that's that there's hope
so the internet of things is a whole
bunch of stuff and unfortunately as the
hype increases you know the breadth of
what the internet of things is grows so
it is now going to be everything it's
not even the internet of everything it's
just going to be everything
because marketing says you know has to
be that um but as tom mentioned one of
the things that most people don't unders
don't realize is that cars have our very
large electronic controls
machines today and they are going to be
internet
in the near future so they are going to
be part of the internet event of things
there's a lot obviously there's a lot of
sensors for fitness
and that's a big
modern thing there's a lot of home
devices that are getting connected up
and of course nest and then picture
frames and various other things
that are that you probably think about
already um now if you break down the
internet of things you could break it
into various different areas and i think
one of the biggest areas today is
industrial automation and the problem if
you can if you include everything in the
internet of things is that you won't be
able to say anything about really the
internet of things because the area is
so broad so i think it makes sense to
think about this as kind of different
application areas there's industrial
automation there's home area networks
there's personal things that you wear
and then there's network devices in your
home
and it turns out this industrial
automation is a very different set and
actually already is a relatively large
market and it has a
different set of problems so we're not
going to be really looking at that but
we are going to be looking at sort of
the home personal area and network
devices within your home that's kind of
the space that we're going to be looking
at initially um and we're not initially
going to be looking at autos or other
things because that's more on the
industrial side
now
and i'd attribute this if i could
remember who told me this but it was
some very wise person once told me when
i was looking at cad tools is that if
you want to build a tool to help you
become more productive the first thing
you have to ask is what is it going to
prevent the user from doing
because if you don't prevent the user
from doing something you can't possibly
provide very much help
because you only know within your tool
something about
something some region something specific
and so if we're going to try to improve
the internet of things we're going to
have to redra
re restrict the space of what we're
talking about
so we think about the internet of things
as being an mgc architecture now what
the heck is an mgc architecture what m
stands for embedded because i can't
spell um
it wasn't it wasn't my abbreviation you
know i'm part of a team here i'm trying
to go with the team
so
most of the internet of things consists
of a thing so the thing is an embedded
system usually has a small processor
it's energy restricted a whole bunch of
stuff so these are parts of the m space
that typically communicates because it
has low energy constrained wireless it
communicates to a local device generally
a gateway device most often today a cell
phone but something
the the beacon that the little device
talks to
and of course then that gateway goes to
see
the c is the cloud basically it connects
into the internet into some kind of
server space
okay and if you think about a large
class of these internet of things they
are going to be a device connected to a
gateway connected to the cloud now you
can argue with me that you don't need
the gateway in all cases whatever i
don't care i'm going to build a system
that has that because that satisfies a
large percentage of things and if i keep
that architecture constant then i have
some hope of basically providing
automation tools
okay and then once the data's in the
cloud you obviously can access it by
various kinds of user devices
everybody with me
okay now one of the reasons that
developing these systems is so hard and
security is so hard is that you have to
build the embedded thing in you know
usually some c or embedded c low-level
programming language and you're
typically programming on arms or you
know avrs or maybe some
ti msp430 some relatively simple
processor then you go to the gateway
device
and you know if you're an iphone person
it's objective c going to swift and if
you're a
google person it's basically java or
javascript right and then
the last part of the application you're
trying to build is something that runs
in the cloud so you're building some web
service backend
okay these are all different
languages you have to have expertise in
and you have to have your application
communicate across all that it gets
complicated
and because of that complexity
security is hard you know you're dealing
with a distributed system you've got to
deal with devices of different places
they have different languages different
os's different networks very different
computational resources between you know
your teeny wheeling processors over here
to google in the cloud there's you know
many orders of magnitude different
reasoning about the overall system is
hard especially when you're writing the
detailed code on all the different
levels
and then probably the biggest problem is
look
everybody wants to make money
right so you don't make money by having
security you make money by developing
the application so what do you focus on
when you're a startup and you're
thinking about this you focus on how do
i deliver the service to the people how
do i develop this thing um and because
security is hard i'll worry about that
later right
and then you get you ship the part and
you kind of like it all works and right
and then you get to the disaster i
talked about in the first slide
okay
so hopefully i've given you a little
introduction to what you know
introduction things is and talked about
what the problem is so what are we going
to do about it
we have really two goals
the first goal is to
try to think about cryptography or
different ways of doing security
that
will make it
sort of naturally safer
to do the kind of computation we're
trying to do so one thing that would be
great is could you encrypt the data
basically in the embedded device
and leave it encrypted all the way up
well
yeah you can do that but if you do that
you can't don't get any advantages of
aggregation
because if you have encrypted data you
can't reason about encrypted data so
what are you going to do so what is the
trade-off there that you can do
and the second thing is
basically can we build can we solve
tom's second problem
which is the design complexity can we
make it easier to construct these kinds
of systems and again can we do that if
we constrain the space into this
particular class of iot devices that
we've been thinking about
okay so let me talk about each of those
in a little bit more detail i already
said there are two kinds of security
there's data security and system
security um so for data security this
basically limits what an attacker can do
with your data
unfortunately it also limits what you
can do with your data
right so there's a trade-off here
because the more capabilities that you
can do with your data and aggregation
the least secure the less secure your
data is going to be
okay and our goal and the way we're
going to think about this is all in
terms of end-to-end security it doesn't
matter that the gateway's secure and it
doesn't matter if you know the cloud
secure if you can read the data through
the pipe as nsa has shown you know if
the data or target right showed right
there in the in the system that was
initially hacked with all the credit
cards
the the card the data came in the whole
system dealt with it and
encrypted but you know over here it was
not encrypted that's where they put the
thing and that's where they stole the
credit cards
so how do you get the the encoding
as close to the device as possible
right so that it's harder to steal the
data along the way
um so what is n10 security it's pretty
simple it says the data gets originated
in a device it's in unencrypted form you
encrypt it you deal with it on the
gateway device encrypted in the cloud
it's encrypted and it only becomes
decrypted on your personal device so
that nobody else if they broke into
those systems could actually
read your personal data
okay
but how can we possibly do that how can
we basically encrypt data
and do any kind of useful aggregation on
it
because the whole reason we're building
this internet of things is so we can
learn things and we can compare our
water usage to other people in the
neighborhood or whatever you want to do
so there's a really interesting
invention that happened about five years
ago called homomorphic encryption
so what is homomorphic encryption it was
the realization that i can take a sensor
value i can take a value s and i can
encrypt it to be s e
something else
but unlike most encryption
it's actually possible to do computation
on sc so i could take two essies and i
could add them together i can multiply
them whatever else i don't know what
they are
but i could do an operation on them
and then you can give me that operation
that the result back
and i can then decrypt it and tell you
what that product was even though you
who did that multiplication don't know
what the numbers are
okay it's pretty amazing
okay
now they proved you can do this in
general the problem is it's about a
million to a billion times slower than
doing it normally
okay really interesting if you're
theorist not so interesting if you're
trying to build an internet of thing
thing
right
but
it turns out
that for specific computations
there are ways of doing the encryption
that if you only needed to do addition
or linear operators you can do this and
it's not that much slower
okay
so what we're going to try to do is
we're going to explore
what kind of encryption we can do what's
the computational overhead of doing
operations with that kind of encryption
and is there some nice boundary that i
can do enough analytics
to satisfy what i what i need without
revealing what the values are okay and
this is a research problem that we're
gonna we're working on
so the faculty member that's working on
this is dan binet who's a cryptography
expert and chris wray who's a data
analytics expert so these are two
faculty members in the cs department
right
and we're going to try to figure out is
it possible for devices to compute in
aggregate
without revealing their own data
and
the results so far are promising right
but we don't have the right encryption
scheme yet
and that's what we're going to look at
we're going to try to look at what the
trade-off curve is how much analytics
you need to do
to be able to get this done
the second goal that we're trying to do
is to implement this framework that
makes it easier to build the internet of
things
and it turns out that when you build an
application even though the application
has sensor data gateway data server data
the kinds of operations that you're
usually dealing with is you're
collecting some data
and then you're transforming that data
in some way
basically you're averaging it or you're
doing some different view a view of that
data and then you're going to present it
as a graph or a chart or whatever you
want
and so we're going to build a language
that lets you describe
what data you want to collect
what operations you're going to do on
that data and how do you want to present
it
independent of where it's being done in
this space
okay and then what we're going to do is
basically allow you
to or have that tool partition it in
different places to figure out what
makes the most what's the most efficient
for your application
and so
phil lavis has already built a prototype
system called revel for doing this and
david maraciers these are also both um
faculty in the cs department are looking
at how to actually build the system and
deploy it
okay
so of course it's the internet of things
so you have to worry about the
networking aspects and so we have people
working about protocols how to do
some of the different link layers how to
make it very energy efficient how do you
deal with the fact that wireless is a
really crappy link layer right if you're
trying to get data across it's very
unreliable
so
we again have a couple faculty member
keith weinstein and prabal datta keith
is at stanford pro balls at university
of michigan who are working in those
areas
and then the area that i'm personally
most interested in is this thing called
software defined hardware
my stick is that
you know we have this amazing hardware
technology today can do almost anything
the problem is the people who know how
to use the technology are not the people
who know how
what applications to solve right those
people tend not to be the technology
experts and we need to better enable
people to to create hardware or to
leverage the hardware that's available
and so we're we're doing a project
called software-defined hardware which
basically says from this description
that people are writing can i actually
look up in the library give them the
build of materials and have them
basically play around with those
materials to get the form factor they
need for their embedded device so we can
automatically generate the embedded
device for them so they don't have to be
a hardware expert to do that and there's
lots of interesting questions there
because if you automatically generate a
device for somebody you know anybody's
built hardware knows that when it first
comes back it never works
right
i've never built a system i mean even
the systems i built my chips always work
for silicon but they never work the
first time i turn them on
and so you have to work on how you're
going to debug these systems that are
being generated that way
and the last thing i want to say is look
if we're going to build the system the
last thing we have to do is we have to
make it easy to use
because as we all know it doesn't matter
what kind of security you put in the
system if it's too hard to operate
people will just defeat it in very
clever ways and so we have people on the
human computer interaction side to make
sure that the things that we put in are
going to basically be used because
otherwise it's all for naught
okay with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention